[Musique]
et
bonjour à tous bienvenue ici à bruxelles
au parlement européen je suis ravi de
vous retrouver pour un nouveau numéro d'
europe hebdo 30 minutes consacré à
l'actualité européenne dans cette
émission nous irons au royaume uni pour
aborder la question de la gpa la
gestation pour autrui
nous verrons qu'il existe des
législations très différente dans les
pays de l'union européenne
faut-il ouvrir un débat sur le sujet
nous en parlerons avec nos invités des
eurodéputés belges roumains et français
mais tout de suite direction l'allemagne
un scrutin très scrutées dimanche
dernier en bavière
la cs où le parti allié d'angela merkel
est arrivée en tête des élections
régionales
oui mais la presse allemande parle de
débâcle pourquoi et bien parce que la cs
ou affiche un score historiquement bas
ont fait le point sur ces élections qui
pourraient fragiliser en guélat merkel
la chancelière allemande
[Musique]
une victoire au goût de défaite
là c'est sous arrive certes en tête des
élections régionales en bavière mais
avec un score historiquement bas le
parti qui règne est seul sur la région
la plus riche d'allemagne va devoir
composer avec d'autres formations
politiques
bien sûr aujourd'hui n'est pas un jour
facile pour la cso nous prenons ce
résultat avec humilité et nous devons
tirer les enseignements de ce score et
nous devons les analyses et les
électeurs ont boudé la formation
conservatrice tu ils se sont tournés
vers les verts les grands gagnants du
scrutin
c'est génial évidemment c'est un
résultat historique unique et cela
montre que la participation électorale a
été exceptionnel ils doublent leur score
en cinq ans dans une moindre mesure
l'aide et profitent aussi de cet
effondrement l'extrême droite fait son
entrée au parlement régional
nous sommes passés de 0 à 11 % des voix
nous pouvons être satisfaits
c'est un peu plus bas que notre score
aux élections nationales mais dans
l'ensemble on est content une claque
pour la cs ou mais aussi pour les
sociaux démocrates du spd
les deux partenaires de la grande
coalition au pouvoir avec la cd vous
d'angela merkel un avertissement pour la
chancelière
ma rencontre la leçon que je tire du
scrutin de dimanche c'est qu'en tant que
chancelière de cette grande coalition
je dois faire plus attention redonner
confiance et faire que les résultats de
notre travail soit visible par tous
la coalition née dans la douleur
apparaît de plus en plus fragilisé
depuis des mois les tensions sont vives
entre ang et la merkel et son allié
bavarois dont le chef horst seehofer et
son ministre de l'intérieur
un ministre qui multiplie les
provocations contre merkel sur sa
politique migratoire ou sur l'islam une
situation politique complexe pour la
chancelière allemande qui affrontera un
vote des militants début décembre pour
la renouveler ou non à la tête d'un
parti qu'elle préside depuis 18 ans
et pour débattre de la situation
politique en allemagne j'ai le plaisir
d'accueillir au de livres christ à autre
au vol bonjour bon je vous ai député
européen allemande vous êtes membres de
la cd où le parti d'angela merkel
comment expliquez-vous ce mauvais
résultat de votre alliée la csu et bien
je crois que les allemands préfèrent
l'harmonie et à berlin on s'est disputés
pendant ces derniers mois on n'est pas
tout à fait d'accord sur la politique de
la migration on n'est pas d'accord sur
ceux ci est sûre ça et la grande
coalition
bon dans les opinions elle n'est plus si
grande que ça
il y a aussi des difficultés avec les
sociaux démocrates
parce que ils se demandent où est ce
qu'on se trouve qu'est ce qu'on va faire
et tout ça c'est pas un climat très
positif
et puis faut dire aussi que dans la
séance où le président s'est offert et
le premier ministre demain à munich
the doors bons sont pas les plus grands
copains quoi ils se sont aussi disputé
et alors justement certains reprochent à
la cs ou d'avoir tenu un discours trop à
droite trop proche de celui du parti
d'extrême droite de l'afd sur la
politique migratoire sur l'islam est ce
que vous faites ce même constat bon
prince et souhaite toujours du côté plus
conservateurs disons dans le spectre
chrétien démocrate
ça c'est un fait mais d'un autre côté
essayer de vendre des messages qui sont
plutôt d'un autre parti ça ça ne va
jamais quoi alors que les gens préfèrent
l'original
maintenant évidemment la ftf pour la
première fois dans les landes tact
bavière où il faut pas exagérer ils
n'ont même pas 10% et tous les sondeurs
d'opinion 10
c'est le maximum qu'on peut atteindre et
alors vous parliez de cette grande
coalition on le rappelle la grande
coalition c'est la cv ou d'angela merkel
avec à droite la cs ou à gauche les
sociaux démocrates du spd avec des
critiques des deux côtés à sa droite et
à sa gauche est ce que cette grande
coalition peut continuer en l'état pas
en état l quel nom mais sinon la grande
coalition peut continuer bon maintenant
à mon avis je vais vous dire franchement
que j'étais plutôt pour la coalition que
l'on appelait la couille la coalition
les jamaïque avec les verts et avec les
libéraux parce qu'on sentait quand même
un grand besoin de changement mais un
changement comme lundi giscard d'estaing
un changement dans la continuité
ce qu'on remarque toujours dans les
sondages c'est que quand guy la mère
qu'elle fait toujours un bon score mais
mme massi dont le parti on n'est pas
toujours d'accord on trouve on pourrait
changer si elle ça mais dans la
population
elle est bien acceptée parce qu'elle
donne elle est garante d'une stabilité
qui dans le monde dans l'accueil qu'on
la rassure elle est incontestée dans son
parti on l'a vu dans quelques semaines
il y aura des élections pour la
présidente de la cd ou la présidence de
la cd où il n'y a pas de débat d'après
vous ce sera encore une guerre un cas il
y à un débat et il ya je crois à présent
trois candidats 3 complètement inconnu
on ne sait pas exactement qui les
soutient on va voir s'ils continueront à
être candidat jusqu'en décembre
pour l'instant il n'y a personne
disons des des chrétiens-démocrates
connus qui se sont opposés complètement
à qui on dit d'accord je suis prête je
suis prêt à la candidature on a vu vous
en avez parlé des tensions entre la cdo
et la cso notamment sur la question
migratoire et comment gérer cette
question au niveau européen angela
merkel a prôné une politique d'ouverture
en 2015 avant de changer un peu de
positions et ce qu'elles paient
aujourd'hui cette instabilité de la
politique migratoire allemande
oui je crois que oui je crois qu'au
moment où elle l'a dit il faut ouvrir
les frontières je crois qu'elle a eu
raison il
à ce moment là en 2015 il n'y avait pas
d'autres possibilités
on a roulé chasser ou est bon ce n'était
pas possible maintenant ce qui n'a pas
bien fonctionné
c'est tout ce qui s'est passé après
pendant des mois et des mois il n'y a
pas eu un fonctionnement pour la gestion
de ce problème est quand même je trouve
que les gens le sentent bon le ce sens
sont pas rassurés quoi ils se demandent
mais qu'est ce qui se passe qu'est ce
qui se passe et que fait notre
administration que c'est la politique
on l'a vu angela merkel et l'allemagne
en général c'est un poids politique très
important ici dans l'union européenne
est ce que le fait d'avoir une situation
internationale complexe ça fragilise
angela merkel sur le plan européen
je ne suis pas membre du conseil
européen alors je ne le sais pas
tellement bien que ça non j'ai
l'impression que la position de merkel
est quand même très forte au niveau
européen et je prouve aussi que elle a
une bonne politique européenne
à ces ouvertures européennes mais faire
quand même attention à ce que les états
nationaux s'y retrouvent dans cette
politique à mon avis c'est bien
évidemment si après le congrès du parti
dans quelques mois
en grammaire qu'elle serait fragilisée à
berlin son influence diminuera un moment
ou à un autre mais il faut dire que d'un
autre côté elle est depuis 13 ans
chancelière et c'est quand même c'est
long dans le système médiatique actuel
je vous remercie infiniment relie veut
christau troubled avoir accepté de nous
éclairer sur la politique allemande
on part à présent au royaume-uni là-bas
la gpa la gestation pour autrui est
autorisée depuis une trentaine d'années
elle concerne environ 200 bébés par an
notre journaliste ras aby cas à
traverser la manche pour recueillir les
témoignages de ses parents d'intention
et de ces mères de substitution
regardez ce reportage on en débat tout
de suite après avec nos invités
à 36 ans caroline est enceinte mais le
petit garçon qu'elle porte elle ne le
gardera pas caroline et mères porteuses
à whistler j'ai grandi fasciné par la
grossesse la naissance et ses histoires
d'infertilité que connaissent les gens
je savais que dès que j'aurai eu mon
premier enfant
j'aiderai les gens et pour moi c'est
facile de le faire
crysis 2 caroline est célibataire elle
est maman d'une fille de 13 ans et en
quatre ans elle a enchaîné trois
grossesses pour d'autres couples c'est
le garçon que j'ai dans mon ventre
c'était il ya sept ou huit semaines
c'est super d'avoir ses échographies
petit clifford il scanne à chaque fois
elle a donné ses ovocytes
ce bébé qui arrive est donc
biologiquement le sien elles sont ses
parts à une semaine après sa naissance
sans états d'âme avec les parents vous
avez une amitié normal donc le bébé est
toujours dans votre vie je suis prête à
leur donner leurs bébés et à récupérer
mon corps ont arpenté par que ce soit
et sa vie de mère porteuse est loin
d'être terminée je veux aider un maximum
de personnes avant d'avoir 40 ans et je
vais recommencer dès l'année prochaine
tu as fleury
caroline pourra être mère porteuse
autant de fois qu'elle le souhaite
la loi britannique qui date de 30 ans
est extrêmement souple toute femme peut
devenir mères porteuses sans condition
particulière et pour le couple demandeur
il suffit qu'ils soient résidents grande
bretagne en revanche la loi interdit de
rémunérer la gpa saha a été mère
porteuse quatre fois elle est aussi
présidente d'une des trois associations
qui met en relation les familles mais
pour moi c'est très important que la gpa
reste éthique et altruiste en grande
bretagne la gba ici est basée sur le
respect et la confiance et c'est
important de savoir pour l'enfant qu'il
est né grâce à une bonne action voilà on
estime à 120 le nombre de mères
porteuses en grande bretagne
[Musique]
victoria philippe et steve ont aussi
décidé de faire un bébé à 3 avant de six
ans la jeune femme n'a jamais eu
d'enfant dans quelques jours elle se
fera ainsi miné un embryon pour ce
couple homosexuel je fais ça parce que
je veux aider les gens
je ne veux pas d'enfant moi même et je
trouve que c'est du gâchis
si je peux porter des enfants pourquoi
est-ce que je n'aiderai pas ceux qui ne
peuvent pas en avoir
en tant que femme j'ai aussi envie de
savoir ce que ça fait d'être enceinte
mais je ne veux pas de l'enfant mais que
se passerait-il si victoria décidé
finalement de garder l'enfant
la loi britannique les six semaines à la
mer pour se décider quant aux parents
s'ils voulaient ne plus garder le bébé
les textes ne prévoient rien la loi est
plus protectrice la gp allait donc baser
que sur une relation de confiance
c'est d'abord une question d'amitié
il n'y a pas de contrat officiel entre
nous car on sait qu'on sera a mis toute
la vie son contrat imposé par la loi
victoria philippe et steve ont conclu un
accord écrit sur mesure que se
passerait-il si steve et moi mourrions
alors que victoria est enceinte
ce seront mes parents qui s'occuperont
du bébé ou ceux de style un groupe de
parlementaires travaillent sur un projet
de réforme pour mieux encadrer la gpa et
gommer ces imperfections
parmi les priorités supprimer le fait
que la mère porteuse soit la mère légale
de l'enfant
parfois même six mois après la naissance
de celui ci elisabeth barker et lord
défenseur des droits lgbt est
ouvertement homosexuel
ce qu'on veut c'est que la loi change
pour donner un statut légal aux parents
qui sont impliqués depuis le début chaud
il devrait avoir la responsabilité
légale dès que l'enfant né
et la loi a déjà évolué après avoir
ouvert la gpa aux couples homosexuels en
le parlement l'a autorisé l'année
dernière aux personnes célibataires
[Musique]
voilà donc pour ce reportage de rats
habitat et pour savoir comment ça se
passe dans les op l'union européenne
j'ai le plaisir d'accueillir maria reina
bonjour un jour vous êtes députée
européenne belge vous faites partie du
groupe de l'alliance progressiste des
socialistes et démocrates ici au
parlement européen
maria gabriela johanna bonjour richaud
vous faites partie du même groupe que
maria arena mais vous venez vous de
roumanie jérôme lavrilleux bonjour je
vous êtes député européen français
membre du ppe le parti populaire
européen alors on a vu comment ça se
passait au royaume-uni ma première
question sera de savoir comment ça se
passe chez vous maria reina en belgique
la gpa est tolérée mais reste assez
exceptionnel exactement donc en belgique
on pratique en fait dans les cliniques
de la fertilité la procréation pour
autrui en fait et donc on peut
effectivement travaillé sur cette
question là mais d'une manière
extrêmement encadrée c'est à dire dans
des hôpitaux qui sont des hôpitaux
publics avec un vrai suivi de plusieurs
années des personnes qui le demandent et
dans le cadre de la question de la
fertilité et donc il y à là il n'y a pas
de loi en tant que tel mais il ya un
système qui permet effectivement d'avoir
une espèce de procréation pour autrui
maria gabriela johanna comment ça se
passe en roumanie
la loi autorise la gpa quelle est la
situation actuelle
en roumanie c'est entendez d'être rendre
passion pour ça ça c'est vraiment que
doit être
à faire juste dans une relation de
respecte de confiance alors sans
d'argent ici je suis d'accord qu'il y a
beaucoup de couples qui ne peut pas
avoir des enfants et la mère de
l'institution de la mer portant c'est
très important pour ce moment il y à
beaucoup de pays qui acceptent cette
réglementation qu'ont les etats-unis
gries canada mais en six dans l'euro
mais il y a encore beaucoup des états
membres de l'union européenne qui
n'accepte pas où la cette institution de
gpa s'est entendu justement en france
jérôme lavrilleux l'egypte est interdite
que vous inspirent ces exemples
européens
ça m'inspire qu'il ya autant de
législation voire d' usage parce que
parfois il n'y a même pas de législation
qui lie à deux pays
en france où l'avait dit rapidement la
gpa est interdite pour tous la pma est
autorisée juste pour les couples auto
hétérosexuels stable c'est pour suppléer
à une infertilité d'un des deux membres
du couple et la france commence à
discuter en ce moment il ya une loi qui
devrait arriver fin d'année début
d'année prochaine au parlement français
pour autoriser la pma pour tous c'est à
dire pour les couples homosexuels
lesbien ou des pour homme ou pour les
personnes célibataires pour l'instant
même ça ça n'est pas autorisée justement
la france va avoir ce débat s'est
autorisé dans d'autres pays
la pma pour les couples lesbiens est ce
qu'on peut légiférer en france il faut
légiférer peut-être il suffit de
traverser une frontière pour avoir accès
à la pma pour un couple homosexuel c'est
toute la problématique puisque il ya
différentes lois alors que les personnes
peuvent circuler et c'est heureux elles
peuvent circuler librement
par exemple sur la procréation
médicalement assistée pour le pardon
excusez moi sur la gpa
vous pouvez aller
procéder à une gpa aux états unis ça se
fait régulièrement se posait un problème
de reconnaissance de l'enfant qui vient
m qui sont ses parents la loi est muette
pour l'instant mais la cour de cassation
qui est de la plus haute instance
judiciaire française
elle a décidé de prendre une position
officielle oblige les tribunaux
maintenant à reconnaître l'état c'est ce
qu'il faut un débat européen la famille
n'est pas dans le champ de compétence de
l'union européenne mais est ce qu'il
faut quand même que les pays européens
se mettent d'accord débattent de cette
question et je crois que doit être une
loi et canon pour tous les états membres
de l'union européenne parce que après la
procréation les procédures légales sont
très compliquées alors s'ils sont
différents d'un pays de notre pays
il y as très difficile pour reconnaître
l'enfant
aussi il y a autre conséquence légale
qui arrive après ça justement maria
reina une réglementation au moins sur la
filiation
on voit que les spas les états sont
parfois démunis se tourne d'ailleurs
vers la cour européenne des droits de
l'homme bien souvent bien sûr je pense
qu'il ya deux deux questions à se poser
le débat est bien entendu important au
niveau européen à la première et je
pense que ça nous réunit tous au niveau
européen c'est que en europe s'il y a
des possibilités d'avoir des gpa dans
certains états membres
on voit que la question de la
commercialisation du corps est
extrêmement je dirais refusé
actuellement et je pense que c'est
important qu'on puisse aujourd'hui en
europe à avoir ce débat dans quel cadre
nous pouvons réfléchir sur la gpa et
donc la question de l'éthique et la
question de l' approche non commerciale
de ces gpa est extrêmement importante et
beaucoup de pays européens en tout cas
partage ce point de vue la deuxième
chose et on l'a dit c'est la libre
circulation des personnes sur le
territoire européen qui est un des
droits et des piliers fondamentaux de
l'europe c'est-à-dire qu'un moment quand
un enfant est là avec des parents et
bien il doit avoir les mêmes droits
partout en europe et donc il y à un
exercice de reconnaissance qui doit être
fait au niveau du territoire européen
donc nous
même si ce n'est pas dans les
compétences européennes nous avons
l'obligation de réfléchir à cette
question
pour garantir le droit de l'enfant et
des parents maria gabriela jouanna
mariait rehn a parlé de gpa éthique en
roumanie par exemple il n'ya pas loin
d'avoir une rémunération mais pas s'être
vraiment à ce que cette règle est
respectée
ou est ce qu'il ya des abus dans votre
pays la raymond une rémunération s'est
totalement interdite pour c'est pour
séduire mais on doit aussi avoir on doit
tient compte de facteurs
ce n'est pas d'anti tous les états
européens l'adoption des enfants pour
les couples lgbt
c'est ce n'est pas facile pour ce n'est
pas acceptée dans l'étude des étangs des
ça c'est difficile aussi parce que nous
mon opinion est que nous devons avoir
une loi également pour tous les états et
on doit régler ça parce que pour la à
cause de la circulation libre des
personnes en couple peut avoir pour
parfaire cette procédure une créée par
action
et après qu'est ce qu'il va faire avec
les enfants il existe en france il est
en couple français dont jérôme
lavrilleux quand on voit le débat en
france très passionné sur la pma et
surtout sur la gpa
on se dit qu'avoir un débat au niveau
européen c'est encore plus compliqué non
je crois que dans les faits ce sera un
peu plus simple pour une raison très
particulière c'est que si vous êtes
membre du club de l'union européenne
mais même si dans votre pays vous
décidez et c'est une décision souveraine
de chacun des pays
l'europe ne veut pas l'imposer de ne pas
reconnaître la gpa de ne pas reconnaître
la pma voire de ne pas reconnaître le
mariage pour tous mais si dans un des
pays où le mariage pour tous est
reconnue et que vous avez le statut
marital hommes femmes
si vous allez vous installer dans un
autre pays où ce n'est pas autorisé ils
doivent le reconnaître et vous avez les
mêmes droits que n'importe quel citoyen
romain donc c'est de toute façon même si
c'est pas dans les compétences de
l'union
c'est un sujet qui s'imposera au fur à
mesure à tous les membres de l'union
européenne la seule chose c'est que dans
un pays les propres citoyens du pays
pourront être avoir moins de droits que
les personnes du pays voisin qui vient
de s'installer dans votre pays où c'est
reconnu mais ça devient donc un débat
européen
maria reina à l'heure actuelle on ne
peut pas dire que chaque pays a sa loi
on est obligé quand même de regarder
justement ce qui se fait ailleurs
il faut ouvrir des débats en union
européenne sur des questions sociétales
qui pour l'instant ne sont pas forcément
très présente
bien sûr je pense qu'on a eu le même
débat sur la question de l'avortement on
a eu exactement ces difficultés dans
certains états membres sur la question
de l'avortement et on a vu par exemple
en irlande que finalement ça a pu
progresser parce qu'aussi il y a eu ce
débat qui a été posée au niveau européen
et qui a fait une forme de
d'entraînement vis-à-vis des pays en
question parce que les femmes
irlandaises à les pratiquer l'avortement
dans d'autres pays donc ça les mettait
en difficulté
donc je pense que ça a pu évoluer donc
c'est là tout l'intérêt d'avoir ce débat
au niveau européen et vous j'ai une
laverie yeux vous vous diriez autorisons
la gpa au niveau européen mettons des
règles encadrent on l'a à titre
personnel moi je suis tout à fait
favorable à la pma je souhaite que cette
loi aboutisse le plus rapidement
possible et même si je suis de droite
je ne suis pas majoritaire dans mon camp
je suis tout à fait favorable à la gpa
moi je mets une seule barrière c'est non
à la marchandisation du corps le corps
ne veut pas être valorisés
financièrement les dés lors que vous
respecter ce critère qui est des
critères éthiques
par exemple par au reportage que vous
avez montré moi je fais partie de ceux
qui pensent que la mère porteuse ne peut
pas faire de don de ses ovocytes
il doit pas y avoir de filiation
génétique pour la mère porteuse
ce qui se fait par exemple aux états
unis où ça doit être issus d'une
fécondation in vitro
il faut que ce soit une personne qui
soit bien entendu stable dans la vie
parce qu'il s'agit pas de tomber dans
des raids dans des dérives
j'y suis totalement favorable moi ce qui
m'intéresse c'est le désir d'enfant et
le bien-être de l'enfant après dernière
question de maria gabriela azoumana vous
faites partie d'un pays la roumaine qui
est un pays
croyant chrétien est ce que ces
questions de la pma de la gpa sont des
sujets tabous dans votre pays
bref on en parle assez librement le
débat public existe à mon collègue a pas
prêt avant reprise en vitraux qui
maintenant roumanie à connaître a connu
une grande espaces mais comment j'ai
déjà dit maintenant je perds c'est une
question des autorités nationales
je crois que mon devoir commencer on
donne on a début on doit commencer une
liberté dans le débat en le baril non de
la bid dont le papa maintenant débat le
tout
stats même de l'union européenne parce
que c'est une question de législation
commune et après quand est ce qu'on va
faire qu'on une enfant qui a été menée
[Musique]
ok mais après il doit vivre en france
merci beaucoup c'est la fin de ce débat
merci à tous les trois d'avoir accepté
notre invitation
vous pouvez retrouver cette émission
europe hebdo sur nos sites internet lcp
public sénat et la rtbf
bonne semaine à tous prochains numéros
d'europe et de la semaine prochaine
[Musique]